These are some things I prep
to make my week just a little bit easier.
I started off by making a blueberry lemon loaf.
So I took some Greek yoghurt zest in my lemon,
added some honey as my sweetener,
some eggs to my liquid batter,
and then added that to my dry batter.
Give it a good mix,
added some blueberries,
and pop that in the oven.
Once that was done,
I let that cool while I started on my pickles.
I was doing different pickles.
I was doing a classic cucumber pickle with some garlic,
bay leaves, dill,
and then I also decided to just do my classic pickled
onion that I do almost every week.
I top that with some peppercorn
and then my vinegar mixture,
close my jar UPS
and set those aside while I started on my granola bars.
My kids are obsessed with these.
I combine some honey with peanut butter
and then add my oats and whatever toppings you like.
I opted for white chocolate chips,
some dried cranberries,
some chia seeds,
and flax seeds.
I put those in the fridge for about an hour
before slicing them up,
and then I got started on my salad for the week.
This week I wanted to go
for something that is super filling
but stores well,
so I did some quinoa, kale,
carrots, some feta,
some cucumber,
and top that with a miso lemon dressing.
I like prepping one hot meal a week.
Just Because I
don't like eating the same meals over and over again,
so I just do one hot meal,
which this week was yaki udon.
So we had some wagyu lying around.
I added that to the pan,
gave that a saute,
pulled that out,
and then sauteed all of my vegetables.
Once those were done,
I added my noodles and my sauce,
gave that really good mix,
and it was done.
I like storing all of my food in glass containers
if I can. So I put my granola bars back in the fridge,
packed away my salad,
and then moved on to my noodles.
I didn't put the lid on
because they were still pretty hot.
And this wraps up my meal prep.